tout repose sur en gros le triptyque
c'est le discours politique ambiant
c'est une application dont on connaît
d'avancé l'efficacité et puis les
pauvres soignants en fait donc en fait
tout repose sur eux donc en fait tout
repose sur et ce n'est absolument pas
audible dans une démocratie telle que la
france ce n'est pas possible
et donc là on est en train de payer
simplement le détricotage 10 public
aujourd'hui c'est l'hôpital demain ce
sera l'école enfin c'est un ensemble et
seront des services publics vitaux à une
nation souveraine autonome résiliente et
c'est donc on a un énorme sujet / / / /
l'infrastructure hospitalière
mais quand vous dites on aurait pu avoir
des millions de défibrillateurs de masse
et des romances heureux que faire en
réalité la question sous jacente c'est
la question finalement de la
responsabilité de l'état
et qu'est ce que finalement l'état et
tous ces risques la pandémie terrorisme
guerre guerre bactériologique y sont
déjà prévues par la cia dans le rapport
de prospective de la cia pour 2035 les
guerre bactériologique sont déjà prévus
donc on peut pas dire qu'on ne sait pas
on peut dire qu'on ne se prépare pas on
peut dire qu on n'anticipe pas on peut
dire que on se fiche de la carte des
risques ou qu'on ne sait pas gérer ça
parce qu'on est à courte vue
est-ce qu'on est dans une doxa quand
même de courte vue parce que on est sûr
de la technocratie pur et dur mais on ne
peut pas dire qu'on ne sait pas
anticiper les risques et c'est en ce
sens que ça pose un vrai sujet des tic
d'état a finalement été et qu'est ce
qu'on en a à part de la technocratie
gestionnaire
[Musique]